femme vit liberté c'est au rythme de ce
slogan scandé par les manifestants que
bat le cœur du mouvement révolutionnaire
à l'oeuvre en Iran
depuis la mort tragique de Marseille
mini les Iraniennes et les Iraniens
investissent courageusement et
quotidiennement les rues en Iran
le bilan est très lourd après deux mois
et demi de contestation populaire près
de 500 morts parmi lesquels de nombreux
enfants des centaines de blessés et plus
de 16000 arrestations et malheureusement
le décompte continue chaque jour de
s'alourdir
ce sont les cheveux au vent la liberté
chevillée au corps et l'espoir en
étendard que les femmes iraniennes
rejoindentes par les hommes se battent
courageusement pour leurs droits
des citoyens de tous âges et de toute
classe sociale
le sang versé par les victimes de cette
répression effroyable ne parvient ni à
éclabousser ni à enrayer cette marge
vers la liberté engagée de la mer
Caspienne au golfe Persique
ce mouvement de rejet ne concerne pas
seulement les obligations archaïques
imposées aux femmes iraniennes il
englobe l'ensemble des négations de la
dignité humaine imposées depuis tant
d'années et dont l'obligation stricte du
port du voile dans la sphère publique en
est le symbole le plus visible partout
dans le pays les Iraniennes et les
Iraniens s'opposent à l'ordre
idéologique imposé par le régime d'emola
c'est avec un courage extraordinaire que
le peuple iranien reste debout face à ce
régime qui Sark boot et ce cramponne sur
son appareil sécuritaire préférent tuer
sa jeunesse puis de que de faire la
moindre concession oui les images qui
nous parviennent de toutes les régions
du pays et se malgré l'injustifiable
censure des autorités nous horrifie au
travers de cette résolution que nous
soumettons aujourd'hui nous députés
Renaissance associé aux députés modem et
horizons que je remercie tenons à
apporter notre soutien plein et entier à
ces femmes et ses hommes
nous pouvons donc madame la ministre que
saluer la décision récente du Conseil
des droits de l'homme des Nations Unies
de créer une mission d'enquête sur les
nombreuses violations commises par la
République islamique en réponse aux
manifestations les menaces les
surveillances les détentions arbitraires
les tortures et les abus sexuels sexuels
pardonnez-moi doivent cesser
immédiatement
quelques jours après la journée
internationale contre les violences
faites aux femmes le vote de ce texte
permet de dire clairement à cette
tribune il ne peut exister de liberté
sans liberté de la femme
c'est pourquoi notre texte demande
l'exclusion de la République islamique
d'Iran de la Commission de la condition
de la femme des Nations Unies
dès le début de la répression vous aviez
madame la ministre condamné avec la plus
grande fermeté ses atteintes massives au
droit humain en Iran le 4 octobre
dernier je vous interroge sur
l'effectivité de possible sanctions
européennes contre les dignitaires
iraniens responsables de la répression
vous y répondiez alors positivement en
attente d'une concertation avec nos
partenaires européens position
d'ailleurs clairement exprimée par le
Président de la République le 11
novembre dernier
c'est désormais chose faite puisque le
14 novembre le Conseil de l'Union
européenne a adopté une deuxième série
de sanctions ciblant pas moins d'une
dizaine d'entités et une trentaine
d'individus responsables de violation
grave des droits de l'homme en Iran
si nous approuvons bien sûr ces
sanctions nous appelons à les renforcer
par ailleurs rappelons que 7 de nos
ressortissants sont également toujours
détenus arbitrairement en Iran et mes
chers collègues en votant ce texte notre
assemblée tout entière à l'opportunité
de leur témoigner un message clair nous
ne vous oublions pas
nous demandons leur libération immédiate
et l'accès à la protection consulaire
l'Iran doit respecter ses engagements
internationaux
le peuple iranien parvient aujourd'hui à
incarner la lutte pour les valeurs
universelles que sont les droits de
l'homme valeur pourtant si décrié par
certains aussi bien d'ailleurs au
Moyen-Orient qui s'y en Occident
à l'occasion de la réception des 4
militantes iraniennes à l'Elysée le
président de la République leur a
justement rappelé je cite notre
admiration notre respect et notre
soutien car leur combat est celui d'un
universalisme de liberté auquel nous
croyons
il est de notre devoir comme patrie des
Lumières de répondre à cet appel
alors mes chers collègues au-delà de nos
divergences politiques qui peuvent
s'exprimer relativement souvent ici
envoyons un message fort au peuple
iranien à la diaspora iranienne et au
descendants d'Iraniens dont je fais
modestement partie une nouvelle fois le
monde regarde la France soyons au
rendez-vous de ces attentes
le scrutin est ouvert
voici le résultat du scrutin votant 149
exprimé 149 majorité 75 pour 149 contre
0 l'Assemblée nationale a adopté à
l'unanimité bravo
[Applaudissements]